Họ thủ tướng kinh bộ trưởng ngoại giao thay lan do lâm xanh mở ra được lực mời trọc quan hệ đủ tác trên nước quan dễn giữa hành lực.
Đúng thời gó phần link hình hợp tác cho giá đoạn hát trên thế theo trong bài viết đăng trên báo đơn nATION ngày hôm sau thăm năm.
Ông xí xa xa trọc biệt, quan hệ kinh tế Việt Nam thay lan đang ngay gặp gặn gắn kế xấu giọc.
Thay lan hệ là đủ tác thương mại lớn nhất của Việt Nam trong ASEAN.
Tông khi Việt Nam là đối tác lượng thứ 2 của thay lan trong khối, kinh gặp thương mại sông phương đa khoảng 2.0.
Và đa hưởng tướng tế hoặc làm tị đoà mi.
Theo ông xí xa xa xa, hành nên kinh tế mà tính bộ trọc thay vì cạnh trên chế biệt.
Kinh nhớ sản thẩm trung dán của thay lan được tiếp tục sản xuất tại Việt Nam trước khi xuất cầu ra thì chừng toàn cầu.
Ông cho giá ngô hình liên ghét trộ ấy cùng ở ngày sẽ trở thành nền tạm tắc lâu dài rồi hành lợp.
Mại đếc cùng nhận mại trở lượng bà kinh nổi gồm kinh nổi trở cùng ứng, kinh nổi tình tế đi phương, bà kinh nổi phát triển bên bứng.
Nông thời cho rằng thay lan và Việt Nam cần tiếp tục với hợp trở trẻ hơn nữa trong hợp tắc mấy công và cùng vô bài trọc chúng tâm quá ASEAN.
Chứ các Việt Nam điện chính chi chỉ trong khu dật.